foreign
ER shows up at my front doorstep but not
a word
I think my parents are in some kind of
trouble oh Ashley's in trouble what is
it this time
get on that flight and do not come back
without my hard drive
purpose for your visit pleasure
lay low for a few minutes
welcome to the island I'm losing my
patience
[Music]
kills him I just got out of there with
my life did you shoot me I guarantee you
there's more men that are already coming
and they will not stop until we are all
dead
come on Ashley
who are you
the old guy he keeps killing everybody
everybody
who is this guy my dad's an assassin
isn't he
your dad's totally unassette
[Music]
here have some more syrup sweetheart